Many people say this, Jesus died for our
sins.
>> Yeah. When he when he going back to God
Yeah. he went back to the Lord.
>> Yeah. After that, the Christianity
become very weak.
>> No, brother, it boom. When you see like
our type of content, what what do you
think? Cuz I know I see nothing. I'm not
the right person to talk about. We're
learning about the Islamic center here.
Do you live in the neighborhood here?
All right, no conversation really. The
Hadith is not word for word. Okay. It's
not preserved 100%.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Come on.
>> [laughter]
>> He He He's So he told you to avoid us.
So somebody come look at this, man. This
This is how you know that this is really
a Muslim community. This house isn't
even sold yet. It is for sale.
Okay? Now look at the top here. Already
got the Arabic name, the Arabic writing
up there. This is a Muslim community.
You ain't moving into these houses
unless you don't say your shahada.
We are in Dallas, Texas in Irving,
ladies and gentlemen. Full Muslim
community. We got the masjid right here,
Islamic Center of Irving. Neighborhoods,
houses, all Muslim communities. Guys,
with all the drama that's been going on,
with all the protests, anti-Islamic
protests, the women coming out
protesting against Islam out here in
Texas, we had to come and see what all
the fuss is about.
>> our physical jihad duty to fight the
entire Earth until we enter it into the
ummah. We should love what Allah loves
and we should hate what Allah hates.
I proclaim the name of the Lord Jesus
Christ over the capital of Texas.
I stand against Islam and THE FALSE
PROPHET MUHAMMAD. Can we get a Can we
get Islam will never dominate the United
States and by THE GRACE OF GOD IT WILL
NOT DOMINATE [music] TEXAS. Islam is a
religion of rape and this is a people of
where they bow down to a stupid rock and
a false prophet.
Go back in your
Go back in your cage, dog. Go back to
your Muslim land. Go back to your land.
We're rolling. We're rolling. We're
rolling.
So come with us. Let's see if we get
some conversations. We're trying to see
you know, just learning about the
Islamic community around here. We're
Christians. We want to just see if we
get some conversations with Muslims.
When Do you You can go there with the
office. In the office? That's where they
have the conversations? Okay, awesome.
Thank you for that, sir. How How long
has this been built?
>> 20 years. And it's a school? Is it Is it
as long as long and a mosque as well?
Oh, that's awesome. Wow, okay. And what
about
the Dawah to like Are there people that
do Dawah? Go out and And okay, and they
share Islam?
Well, I appreciate you sharing that.
Absolutely. Crazy thing about this,
guys, is you can literally see
the connectivity with the Islamic center
and the neighborhood. So you have the
houses right here. You see this gate
that they put up? All you got to do is
come through this gate and boom, you're
here at the masjid. You're here at the
Islamic center. The kids don't got to
really go too far. The wives don't got
to go too far. The men don't got to go
too far. You can literally have them
Islamic center basically in your
backyard like this. It's really crazy. I
remember like in my old neighborhood, we
had something like this that led to a
park. And so like a lot of neighborhoods
would have this connectivity with a
park, but this one has it connected to
the Islamic Center. So, it's really
getting serious out here in Dallas,
y'all. They're really trying to come
over here and
populate Dallas with Islam. So,
what we going to do? So, we got the
Islamic writing here. I mean, it's not
just this, guys. When you guys go into
the neighborhoods, the street names, the
boulevards, they're all named after
Muslim characters, Muslim people, Muslim
places and locations.
Um That's what it's like. It's really
serious. How you doing, sir? Uh do you
live in the neighborhood here?
Yeah. Uh can you can you tell us a
little bit about the neighborhood?
>> time.
Oh, what what what what's going on right
now? Huh? You saying it's a prayer time
right now?
>> 1:15.
Okay, so it's prayer time.
The prayers don't really last that long.
They really are short, so maybe when
they come out of the prayer time, we can
actually probably get some conversation.
All of this
This is the Muslim neighborhood. All of
it. If you don't believe me, come on,
let's look at the sign. Let's look at
the street names. Look at the sign right
here, Alhambra Valley. Not just this, we
going to show you guys the others as
well. Alhazen Street. Hey, man, where
you live, man? I live on Alhazen Street.
High-rise houses, too, man. Al-Razi
Street, next to Alhazen Street. I'm
telling you guys and look at the houses,
man. Bad houses. You want to know why?
Because they keep giving to the masjid.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala increases your
gift tenfold, 100-fold. Look at this.
All of these are Muslim houses. And you
mean to tell me that this ain't real?
This is real as it gets. Al-Ghazali
Street. I said I said somebody come look
at this, man. This This how you know
that this is really a Muslim community.
This house isn't even sold yet. It is
for sale.
Okay? Now, look at the top here. Already
got the Arabic name, the Arabic writing
up there.
Uh I'm How much What What do we got to
show y'all? This is a real Muslim
community and they're making it known.
this is a Muslim community. You ain't
moving into these houses unless you
don't say your shahada.
Look at these streets, man. We've got
another street. Baruni
Baruni Street. You know what I'm saying?
You are not getting in unless you have
said your shahada. Repeat after me,
Ash-hadu. And you know when we come to
Texas, y'all, we we got to link up with
the original Quran-only Christians out
here, man. We got the word and I himself
in the building, you know that. Coming
out here to the streets. Yes, sir. So,
what's it like when you're seeing this
stuff develop, Islam kind of flood into
Texas like this from your perspective?
>> Yeah, I mean
from a distance when you ain't it ain't
in your face Yeah. seems like it's far
off, you know what I'm saying? But from
where I stay to here is only 300 miles.
So, it ain't going to take much for it
to come from here to the next pocket
town, to the next pocket town, and then
it's going to be at your footsteps. From
those steps. From from being
where I know Texas was, heavy Christian
state. Yeah, huge. There's There's
There's churches all up and down the
highway like like blocks from each
other. Big church, big church, big
church. It looks like that's what
they're trying to do here with the
masjids and the Islamic centers now.
>> And you know what? They positioned this
masjid
a block from that big Catholic church.
Oh.
It's a big Catholic church right there.
Right in the middle of the Islamic
community that's being built, we also
have a church called Holy Family of
Nazareth over here, a Catholic church
over here.
It's huge.
I mean, literally right next to the
Islamic center. And so, I don't think
that it's a coincidence that the Islamic
center was put here. I don't know I I
actually don't know which is newer, but
I do find it interesting that we have a
huge Catholic church right here and then
an Islamic center that's not too far
off. What y'all think? They being
strategic.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Whether or not, you know, every foot
soldier knows what's going on, you know
what I'm saying? But the upper ones
Yeah, they know what they're doing.
>> They're being strategic and they setting
these mosques up in hubs to where they
know there's a lot of traffic going to
go through. And then a competing
religion right there across
come out of church, what you going to
get?
>> Islam.
>> Islam. Here goes the devil. "So what
Jesus ain't God." You know, and then you
get some some people that ain't really
highly educated and they start to think
like
they got a point.
>> Yeah. And then
the dollar script got them. Now, imagine
the amount of fish we can reach if more
people came out, stepped into the front
lines, studied the Bible, studied the
Quran, and was able to come out here and
give the Islamic dilemma to every Muslim
they walk into. That this would be
powerful. So, we need more people to
step up, get into the front lines so
that you could present the arguments to
the Muslims cuz they're out here.
They're out here. And they ain't going
nowhere. How convenient is it to just
have like the masjid, the Islamic center
in your backyard basically like this,
bro? Oh, it's very convenient.
>> Yeah. So, you can just walk in, you walk
out, walk into your prayers and just,
you know, in and out like that. Yeah.
[clears throat]
>> That's what's up. So,
are there shiekhs, any imams there like
are usually up here leading the prayers
or how does that usually look? How does
that usually work? I mean, yeah, we have
like a few, you know. Yeah, we have some
shiekhs here, you know.
I've always been curious, man. Do they
do they sometimes teach give lectures on
like the previous scriptures before the
Quran like the Torah, the Injil, the
Gospel? Do they ever like teach on these
things and how they relate or I mean
Not I mean, they prob- they probably do.
I mean, I'm not here as much
>> Okay. Okay. We're we're Christians and
so this is all like, you know, it's it's
new to us, you know what I'm saying?
So, we we don't know the like the
culture or like what happens on the
inside like that. So, it's interesting
hearing about like I read the Quran
myself.
Yeah, something that's huge for me
obviously is the as a Christian I like
what the Quran says about the Bible like
the Torah, the gospel how that comes
from God and
you know, like
the Quran confirms that it's supposed to
be in line with this. So, like like if
there it's all supposed to be one big
threat, right? And so, that's that's a
that's a core message that I see like
you have to believe in the prophets,
believe in the books.
However, just a little
issue for me is that when I when I do
put them side by side like if I read the
Torah and gospel and then I read the
Quran, I do see that there is like huge
differences, you know, like core
differences like the crucifixion of
Jesus for example or Jesus God having a
son. Like these are huge differences,
you know. Really big differences. How
would how would you reconcile that if
you were like to if you were thinking
about it like, okay,
like all the scriptures are supposed to
be have the same message? Um
I'll be honest, I have uh
um
I honestly have no idea. Okay, that's
fair. That's fair.
I mean, I'm on obviously still trying to
learn myself, you know. I'm not um
you know, I'm I'm still trying to learn
myself. I'm trying to
learn whatever I can about my religion
and I'm trying to
Of course, I know a little bit about
Christianity, you know, a little bit of
Judaism, but I'm also still trying to
learn more about Islam.
>> That's a humble answer. I would I guess
I would just say just for food for
thought like really consider cuz it's a
huge message like from when I read the
Quran, a huge part of the the message of
Islam is that the the that Islam is the
message of all the prophets. Right? And
that you know, prophet after prophet
after prophet continued to It's a
continuation of the same message.
>> other Abrahamic religion. Exactly.
>> Noah, you know, we believe in Abraham
and Moses and all them. Yep. You know.
Yep. So, so this is it's a huge it's
supposed to be a huge threat. Now, so
the pre- what the previous scriptures
say and what the prophet said, when we
go look at them, that's that's huge when
it comes to the message of Islam. If the
previous scriptures said something
opposite of what the Quran says,
then that's a big issue. If they if if
they're not in line, then
we have there's there's an issue with
what the Quran is saying, you know? Um
because [clears throat] like uh the the
Quran a lot of times leans on like for
example, uh there's a verse in Surah
Yunus.
Um chapter 10 verse 94, it says to
Muhammad, "If you are in doubt about
that which we have revealed to you." I
meaning the Quran. "Then go and ask
those who've been reading the scripture
before you." Right? The truth has come
to you from your Lord, so be not of
those who doubt. So, the Quran points to
the previous scriptures as a place where
you can get where Muhammad can get truth
if he's not sure about what the Quran is
saying,
you know? So, if they're not in line
together, then that's a big problem for
for the Quran. They have to be in line.
Uh I don't want to overflow you with
anything, but you know, just just food
for thought, man. Think about it and uh
really really consider that like, you
know, what do you think? I'm not a
person of knowledge, you know, like with
the I'm not like uh scholar.
>> Yeah, yeah, of course.
>> not like at least like the answers to
your questions, um I wouldn't be able to
give you the proper answers. Well,
listen, I I appreciate you, man. Can I
give you a little hug before Of course.
Of course. It was so nice talking to
you, brother. Of course. Nice talking to
you. Make this left in here right here.
Okay. Yo your camera going get tired of
that
seatbelt noise. Now, you finished your
five daily prayers? Don't you worry
about it. Little hungry? Don't you worry
about sweet heart, because right next to
[music] it, we got a loud burger spot
called Soul Tani. We're going to check
it out real quick to see
>> [music]
>> how they grill up right after the little
prayer. See if it's a good little spot.
See if [music] we can get a conversation
with
the guy at the at the front. I'm going
to lie. It smells really good.
Everything that's sliding on the menu up
there is my is my type.
>> By the way, if it's [music] possible
Yes. Would it be okay to put it on my
face? Absolutely. Yeah, yeah. For sure.
You don't even got to ask, brother.
Yeah. I'm going to put it on my face.
[music] Yeah, yeah, yeah. Perfect,
perfect. We have best Mhm. Mhm. Yeah. So
this place Yeah, yeah, yeah. It doesn't
matter white, brown, black. They say we
make the
>> [laughter]
>> I'm a best seller.
>> [music and singing]
>> I'm a best seller in the kitchen. It's
all for the best seller.
This is a a Muslim establishment, right?
>> Yes. [music] So with
with a bacon cheeseburger, I know that
like pork is haram.
We serve only halal [music] food. Okay.
Yeah.
>> Which means it's not just halal. Mhm.
It's halal halal. Ah. So you don't have
to worry about anything. [music]
Yeah, yeah. It's going to be beef.
Whatever it is.
>> That's what I'm talking about.
Nice. [music]
>> sell pork and we don't sell alcohol.
Mhm.
Yeah, that makes sense.
>> [music and singing]
>> For sure, for sure. Okay. This looks
This going to fill you up right here,
man. See this? This is how you eat
halal. [music]
This is how you eat halal. Tell them.
Now
>> [music]
>> we're doing a little food review. I'm
not going to lie to y'all. I tasted the
This is fire right here. This uh
It got
the the the stuff here.
>> [music]
>> You know, with the
See here? [singing] And it's absolutely
delicious. Oh, you want to bring it more
over here? Woo.
>> [music]
>> Beef nihari? Is that how you say it?
Nihari.
Mhm.
Ah, man. Brother.
Brother. [music] Ah, key.
Cut it in half for me. Look at this. Oh
my god. Look at it right there. Look at
this right here.
This is right up our alley.
Right up our alley. Let's see how it is.
I hope they got cheese on it.
Mhm.
Okay.
Oh,
is there any one left?
All right, my brother. So, you said that
you recognize the channel. Yes.
>> What was that like when you realized
like, wait, hold on a second. This is
I was like, I know his face.
But then I saw God bless you on his
sweater.
>> Ah, that's what gave it away.
>> [laughter]
>> That's so funny. Okay, and so you were
saying um like as a Muslim for you
yourself, you're not a Muslim because
you grew up in it and like this is just
oh, you're following your parents'
religion. You're saying that you're
>> [music]
>> you you've you've seen the evidences and
research. Talk Tell Tell us a little bit
about that. So, the thing is
if God wants me to follow religion, he's
going [music] to give me signs.
So, he made an entire book
filled with signs.
Not s c i e that signs.
The s i g n s, that one. Yeah. So,
[music]
I got all the signs that I needed. She's
the owner. Mhm.
Oh, nice.
Make sure you blur his face.
>> [laughter]
>> So, I got all the signs that I needed.
>> Mhm. One of them I would say
the most strongest one that I got is
God challenged the entire humanity.
Who challenged our prophet that this
book is man-made.
So, God said
if you think that this book is man-made
make one book like
>> something like it. One book like it.
It's been 1,400 years. Not possible.
God also said, "Okay, you don't have to
make the book. Make 10 chapters like
it."
Still wasn't done in 1,400 years.
And God said, "Make [music] one chapter
like it."
Which is still not done.
And God also said, "You can take help
from all of humanity.
Just make one chapter." And the jinn.
Yeah? And the jinn. Cuz I used to bring
the humanity and the jinn. Yeah.
>> Still not done yet. And do you know how
short is a
shortest chapter?
>> Like three verses. Three lines. Three
lines, yeah. Three lines.
This thing is so unique
that it even the whole mankind could
make it yet. And it's an open challenge.
God said, "If you can just do that, you
don't have to worship me anymore. I
won't hold you liable for this." Mhm.
It's still not done for 1,400 years.
What if I told you that someone did meet
the challenge? [music] We want that. I
want that.
I want to see that. What if I told you
it's someone you know? I just show it to
us. Okay. We are going to verify it to
non-Muslim scholars. Mhm. It doesn't
have to be Muslim scholars. Mhm.
All the scholars who learn language,
they said
This is so good, bro. So I'm listening
I'm listening to what you're talking
about.
My gosh. The food This is the um the
biryani.
>> biryani. Beef biryani. Oh my gosh.
The food should be so good that it blurs
your eyes.
>> I know. I'm I'm not distracted. I'm like
I'm trying to listen to him, BUT MY GOD,
this is good.
>> [laughter]
>> All right, go ahead. That's what we
make. That's what we make. That's what
we make. That's what we make. Mhm.
Okay. So, go ahead. I'm sorry. So you
said you would want to see this this
evidence and stuff like that. You
wouldn't shy away from it.
>> One chapter. Okay. God's going to
release me from all liability. Okay.
I'm good. Nothing else. All right. I
have it for you.
Okay? I'm ready to see it. I let Like I
said, I'm not the learned person. We are
going to have the scholars over here.
The the people who are the scholars of
language, they said Arabic is the most
richest language in the [music] entire
world.
>> Mhm.
That's a fact given by scholars, not
just normal people.
Okay.
So, have you do you know who Umar bin
Khattab is?
Uh yes, Sahabah. Yeah, he yeah, he was
one of the Sahabah's, really important
one. Um
and so there's Hadith,
um there's two of them actually that
narrate this
in Bukhari. Mhm.
I'll show you it.
Where
Umar
says that Allah agreed with him in three
things. Mhm. There are three lines. With
Umar. Okay. So First of all, Umar
radiyallahu anhu, peace be upon him,
didn't have direct connection with God.
Good point. He is saying that
God agreed with him in three things, it
could be out of the two that the prophet
said that God accept I mean agreed with
him
or that's not possible.
Okay, so they so that's a good point.
It's that he's not a prophet. He doesn't
have direct revelation, right?
>> [snorts]
>> So I'll get your thoughts on this
because so you'll see that Umar says
these things and then
after he says it Allah reveals it to
Muhammad afterwards.
>> Yeah, that's that could be possible
because the Quran was released or let's
say
what's the word?
I forgot the exact word.
>> Progressively maybe? No,
he revealed the verses according to the
situations that was happening during
that time. Which also makes the Quran
pretty unique. Like he just made the
verses God just made the verses
according to that specific situation
Mhm. and yet it's so artistic that
people are not able to make it yet.
Yeah. You know the challenge, the one
verse challenge. Yeah, so okay, for
sure. So let me see let's see let's see.
My Lord agreed
with me
in three
things. I've just pulled the push that
up and
see what you think about it.
Okay, yeah.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> Verse two of them.
All right, here we go.
Here. You get to Do you read Arabic,
too? Uh I can read it, but I don't
understand it.
>> Okay. I want to do that one day.
>> Bro, I tried
I tried to learn Arabic off YouTube. Oh.
>> I it was so it was so tough, man.
You need a proper teacher. Yes, I do. I
learn I learn better like in class.
Yeah. Yeah. So, narrated Omar
my Lord agreed with me in three things.
I said, "Oh Allah's Apostle,
I wish we took the station of Abraham as
our praying place for some of our
prayers." So, came the divine
inspiration
"And take you people the station of
Abraham as a place of prayer for some of
your prayers, example two raka of tawaf
of of tawaf."
And as regards the verse of
the veiling of the woman, I said, "Oh
Allah's Apostle, I wish [snorts] you
ordered your wives to cover themselves
from the men because good and bad ones
talk to them."
So, the verse of the veiling of the
woman was revealed. Once the wives of
the prophet made a united front against
the prophet and I said to them,
"It may be if he, the prophet, divorced
you all, that his Lord, Allah, will give
him instead
of you wives better than you."
So, this verse, the same as I had said,
was revealed.
Which verse is he talking about? Um six
See, that's chapter 66, verse uh
I should say it. I think it's verse uh
five. Let me see. Yeah, yeah. So, he'll
they put in parentheses there the verse.
Um
So, yeah. So, these will be So, these
are three examples where Omar says
something and then
it gets revealed to Muhammad just as
Omar said it. So,
couldn't someone make the argument that
Omar
did say something or come up with
something that's at least good enough
that was similar enough to be in the
Quran that Allah made it a revelation?
Of course. All right. So, then So, I
would say that
from a critical standpoint, I would say
that it looks like Omar kind of met that
challenge to bring something at least
similar to it.
>> Here's the thing. God said
this book.
After it's revealed,
the challenge is on. Mhm.
It's not before the challenge.
So, if you say that God just said See,
here's the thing. He said it however the
way he said it.
But, God delivered it in an artistic
way.
The Quran is not just because of the
words. It's a linguistic
and there's some patterns of how you say
it, how it sounds.
You just have to talk to a scholar about
it. Mhm. So, let me tell you this.
During Prophet Isa Alayhis Salam, Jesus
Christ, during his time, it was the time
of medicine.
He used to heal people. He put his hand
on a blind guy's eye, I guess. Healed a
blind guy. And it uh got healed. Mhm. He
uh make a dead made a dead person turn
alive.
Right? Am I right?
>> Yeah, yeah. He resurrected the dead,
yeah. During his time, it was medicine.
During Moses, peace be upon him, Musa
Alayhis Salam, during his time, it was
magic. So, I as far as I've heard, he
just threw a rod, I mean, a stick. Heck,
yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> He just threw a He just threw a stick
and turned into a snake.
>> Bro, you have to get the If they can
make a burger without cheese, man,
for you, oh my gosh, this is so good.
All right. I am so sorry, bro. But, you
you know, you
>> enjoy it. You're giving me good
conversation and good food.
>> you if there's no cheese on that, that's
that's going down. Man,
this is delicious. What's the sauce that
y'all put on the burger? I don't make
it. All right.
You just made the order.
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> I don't know if there's cheese, but I
guess there should be cheese. Bro, this
is this is Yeah, I agree. There should
be cheese. Whoever says no cheese,
they're they're an alien.
>> know. I don't know.
>> [laughter]
>> I exactly know what goes on. The owners
know it and the chef he definitely
knows. Yeah, yeah.
How how are the fries? No, this is good
as well. For him obviously cheese. I'm
not a big like um Fries guy?
>> Yeah,
well, I like fries just not a lot of
stuff on it.
But um my my wife should would love
this. She likes this type Why don't you
bring her?
>> [laughter]
>> She's uh she had to work and stuff, so.
How do you like you had the nihari? It's
gone. It's it
I [laughter] told you.
I told you.
It's going to make you go to sleep.
Oh, man. Yeah, this is good. I'mma eat
the rest of this later. Eat the rest of
this later as well. We can pack it up
for you. I appreciate that. Yeah. Yeah,
this is good. All right, so you're
saying
uh So during during the time
It was time of magic. If you were to
take turn into a snake and during our
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him's
time, it was poetry.
Okay. At that time
the the world's best poets were
Arabians I guess from that area. Mhm.
And if you ever hear someone reciting
the Quran, you
you listen to it as if someone's
reciting poet poems.
So the magic was
like you said
uh Omar Abdullah Anhu
he said something and then God turned
into a verse.
He might have said, "I think like it's
better that you cover yourselves."
God wanted that. He revealed it to us
artistically.
That's what That's the short form that I
would use. Okay. We don't know how much
science goes into it. Yeah. Like if you
just research the Quran
have you ever read the whole Quran once?
Mhm?
The whole Quran, the Arabic, have you
heard someone recite to you?
Um, yeah, in some some parts of it,
yeah.
>> So, people they just sit and they they
just hear the Quran and they say, "I
have a connection with it."
Mhm. That's how strong the recitation
is. That's how strong the poem is. Would
you Would you So, yeah, so I I when I
hear these reasons like
a lot of these reasons are like they're
subjective to the person that
experience, you know, like what's
beautiful to them and what's artistic to
them. Like no, you you can't you can't
judge art.
>> one is subjective
and one is common sense. So, what part
is the common sense? The challenges, the
signs, the s i g n s.
>> Okay, so let me go let me go with you on
this. If if like to my to my common
sense, it looked like Omar met the
challenge, right? Your response is,
"Well, you know, I I I see how you can
say that, however, Allah does it in a
more artistic and more beautiful
structure
>> technicality, I can give you the
technicality as well. Okay. Omar
he first said it. Mhm. Then [snorts] God
so revealed it in a different way.
And then he challenged followers. It
wasn't different, though. It will be
different because you So, what you're
reading is
uh what you call
He says exactly He says, "As I said it."
You're right. No, no, what you're
reading is Hadith. Right. The Hadith is
not word for word. Okay. It's not
preserved 100%.
We make We follow Hadith only when it's
authentic. So, there are stages, but
those same authentic Hadith
if
narrated by someone else, you find it it
a little bit different, but both saying
the same thing.
So, by this we are confirming that the
Hadith is not 100% sure that that's the
exact way he said it and that's exactly
the way God revealed it.
We You cannot get that from there
because it's already we already know the
Hadith could be differently said.
Different narrators could say
differently, but they will make the same
sense.
Allah said in the Quran,
make one chapter like it, just like
that.
>> Let me ask you. Yeah. Okay, so
when it says make it like it, right?
Yeah. So, it's not supposed to be an
exact copy.
>> Doesn't have to be exact words. Just
have to follow some things. So, wouldn't
that mean that if if what Umar is saying
in the Hadith is like what Allah said,
it's not exactly
>> Here's the thing again, he didn't say
verse. He did. He said three of them. He
said three lines, and if you go and
follow
those three lines, if it matches with
the Quran's
linguistic, the Quran's poetry level.
Bye-bye, sir. Sorry. Wa alaykumu salam.
It has to match those to fulfill that
challenge. And second of all, it still
has to come after the verse was
revealed. Why Why does it have to come
after? Because once the Quran was
revealed, God said, "Today,
I have perfected the message for you or
completed the message for you." After
that, the challenge turns on. So, I have
a thought about this, then, okay? So,
the Quran is being revealed over 23
years, right? So, it's a progressive
revelation.
>> Yes. Um And by the way, wouldn't that
mean
>> different verses, different times,
>> right? Different situations and context.
It's related to one surah, one chapter.
>> Right, right, right. Wouldn't then um
wouldn't the challenge go for any like
any time the Quran is being revealed
that the challenge is is met? Even even
if Allah said one thing, the very first
time he recited he revealed Surah
Fatiha, verse one, right?
That means the challenge is on. Bring
something like Surah Fatiha, verse one.
So, here's the thing.
We take it as once the book is revealed,
the challenge is on.
So, wait, did you get that from? Because
let's say it was being reviewed. 100
years later you're going to get the
message, right?
Or people of the time. But here's the
thing, if you So I have to talk to
scholar about it, but from my common
sense Yeah.
Allah said in the Quran this Quran is
for whole mankind.
Of course the for the ones who are
coming after.
Yeah. Who are coming after. Not for the
ones who came before. For them it was
the angel the Bible that you got.
For Musa alayhis salaam
it was Torah. For Abraham alayhis salaam
it was different. You man you making a
lot of good points. Let me let me ask
you this, okay? So and and then we get
rested on that part and then for sure.
So the Quran is for all mankind, people
in the future and the people present,
right? So and when when Allah is
revealing these verses and even the
challenge the challenge is to the people
that's present with Muhammad, too,
right? Anybody from that point and
anybody, right? So Umar is included in
anybody that's there is included in
that. So in the time of Muhammad Umar a
companion is able to come up with three
things three lines, right? And and by
the way the Quran
existed before it even was revealed to
Muhammad, right? In the
the tablets, right? In the mother of the
books right?
Okay, for sure. So
you have the Quran is already it's it's
already existing in a thing even if it's
all of it is not revealed just yet.
But then Umar is able to come up with
three things that haven't been revealed
yet but are revelations. First of all I
haven't properly learned those things.
I'm learning that for the first time.
Second of all
if that posed a threat to that challenge
that three those three lines would be
you You
it would be on TV. I don't think so.
>> People dismantle an entire religion.
>> [laughter]
>> Why don't think I don't think that thing
was right enough
for it to be an argument.
>> For sure. I'm not a learned scholar.
Yeah. That's why I said if I had
Muhammad Hijab or Muslim Lantern, they
would love
>> would love to ask them about this. If
they were with me right now, they would
have a proper answer because they're
like checkmating
>> I don't think so. Have you ever seen
[laughter] Have you ever seen Zarkawi?
Yes, yeah. When someone questions him,
he just gets all like checkmate, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> He says he says, "Brother, that's a very
good question. Very good."
I love Zarkawi, yeah. Yeah, he'll be
like, "That's a very good question." And
then he tries to cook. Yeah. Well, man,
yes,
take a look at this I guess a little
later, think about it a little bit, but
yeah, that's just one of the things on
my mind. Um So, is that the only
argument you have for that challenge? Um
for this challenge, no, I have I have
others, but I we don't have time to get
into others, but yeah, we got to get
going. But man, dude, this was
everything. This is awesome, bro. For
real.
So, this is basically this is a red body
challenge. So, if you stop the timer at
10 seconds, you get MSRP Pokemon or free
fries or 10% off your order.
All right, let's see. Let's see if we
can do it.
All right, y'all.
The moment of Al Hook.
Let's see. Eight, nine
>> [screaming]
>> Man, that was a little too close. I was
five decimals off. Man, hold on, man.
Here we go.
Here's the moment of the real Al Hook.
The truth.
Six, seven, eight
nine, 10
All right.
Here we go.
This is it, man. Third time's the charm.
This is what I heard.
Six, seven eight nine 10
>> [laughter]
>> Come on.
One more try? Okay.
I don't know if I can get any closer
than that. Let's see.
Here we go.
All right, guys. This is it, man. For
real this time.
All right.
6 7
9 10 Okay. Yeah.
As you guys know, a little little
consolation prize, you know.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh
look like uh men's Mhm. But yeah. Yeah.
>> Nice cards, though.
>> Thank you. I appreciate it. This made
This made me feel good for getting
close.
>> [laughter]
>> Thank you so much. This was uh this is a
awesome experience. So, all tiny, ladies
and gentlemen, grilling burgers. So, I
grew up in Califor Southern California.
>> Oh, I see. So, yeah. Like so like about
an hour from Los Angeles. And so, um my
my dad, he's a preacher. Got it. Um and
like he always wanted to he got it now
in Arkansas, but he wanted to have like
a a place where we could have a
gymnasium and a community things like
this, you know? So, as a kid, like we
always wanted something like this, bro.
So, this is this is really dope, man.
Is What Is this the biggest Islamic
center in Tex- or at least I guess the
Dallas area, I guess, is it?
>> I think so. Yeah. There's one [snorts]
in Desoto. Maybe bigger than this one.
>> Mhm. Um but this in the neighborhood is
is is what I think is Man, the amount
[clears throat] of work being put into
this place is just insane, man. The idea
is the idea is to have people get away
from alcohol, drugs, all these bad
habits. Mhm. Give them space to come,
play, exert their energies over here.
Yeah. Instead of just hanging out at
different places.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Uh that might not lead them
into good
directions in their lives. Yeah.
And come here and play. Yeah, yeah.
Get them off the street, man. Get them
off the street. This whole place raised
this curtains. Yeah, let me take you
inside. Sure.
Buckets.
Okay. All right, what are with the
behind the back?
>> [laughter]
[laughter]
>> You know, I've never So, is it all You
said it's it's everybody with their
leagues and stuff like that, but for the
sisters and the brothers, these are
mostly Muslim games, right? When you say
Muslim games, what do you mean? Like
members that come here that are Oh, no,
okay.
So, members, they come in for the most
part, all of our the kids who grew up
here, like my kids and other kids who
grew up in this community, they come and
play. Yeah. But not everybody makes it
to the team. However,
there are other teams from Frisco,
Irving, when we open up a tournament
when there's an old tournament
organized, then teams from everywhere
come. Now, on some days, because we have
to dedicate certain days of the week for
different games. For example, tonight
they're going to play badminton. Mhm.
Three or four days of the week they play
basketball. Yeah. And one day they play
volleyball. Yeah. So, different days.
And when it's basketball, a lot of our
kids, they bring their school friends.
Okay, yeah. They come up with a team.
Okay, I bring my team, you bring your
team. It's
just an impromptu game. Yeah, of course.
Pick up game. Yeah.
Mhm.
was housing about close to 180 190
unhoused guests. From the freeze that
was born
from the streets.
Yeah.
Oh, that is cool.
That's cool. I see.
They come in here and then they get
checked
for medicals. They get screened for
anything that they need medical
attention with.
So, they get medications. A lot of
people who have chronic
diseases like diabetes, blood pressure,
high blood pressure, hypertension.
And sometimes mental issues, things like
that. So, we have
the city of Plano paramedics school
here.
They check them out. They take them
sometimes they come in with wounds.
So, the wound care happens and we give
them new clothing closets. We have free
clothes, jackets, everything else.
That's awesome. And then they take it,
they stay here, then they get nice food
and warm food, warm meal, coffee,
everything. They get to watch all the
games. You see those projectors? Right.
Yeah. You know, they love them and they
they say, you know, this is a nice they
lie down on their cots
and then they watch the game.
Football and basketball. They know
exactly the schedule by the way. Of
course they do.
Give them give them something to do.
They know they know the best ones.
The prayer man come who? That's what I'm
talking about, bro. They just like to
come and play and talk to these men.
Man.
Tell them, "Hey, do you want to play
cricket?" They say, "No." Really? Oh,
let me ask you. Eddie, Eddie, do any of
you guys know how to play cricket?
Look, they don't even Oh, yeah, you do?
Oh, that's what I'm talking about. See,
you got one.
>> [laughter]
>> He's showing up, man. YOU BETTER GET
HIM, MAN. GET HIM GET him on camera,
man. We going
Hey, coaches, come scout this one right
here.
No, this is this is awesome, man.
So, what what about the the Dallas
program? Like um
Dallas program, there's no such thing as
going out there and saying, "Hey, now we
got to push them out." Mhm.
People come out of their own volition
and ask questions.
They do so. Hey, what like what do you
stand for what do you do what is your
understanding of this
after the question
and if they come on their own
Yeah for sure okay so there's like cuz
we have a sense of like evangelism and
Christianity
There there's some
some
dollar groups I guess you could say
where they put up tents in certain parts
of popular [clears throat] areas
do they have like is there a team here
that may go out and
We there are people who go out there set
up tables
and then they answer questions obviously
they
going to debates and all of that stuff
but epic doesn't do that
epic what epic focuses on are services
I see Communities people in need free
medical clinics
pack 100,000 meals for
street children everywhere do that every
year Everybody got some guests
They want to see I was just telling them
what the food pantry does
So this guy he does manages the food
pantry
Nice how you doing
He does covers all of this on Saturday
afternoons
Cars just drive in like I said
>> Yeah and just come and pick it up How's
the word get out is it flyers and stuff
No it's word of mouth publicity people
get to know and then we put it on paper
on our Facebook
on our YouTube channel
Instagram so people
they so one family comes they let maybe
the other families know
Yeah cool cool cool cool
And then we have other programs that we
do
the free medical clinic
You know that outdoor basketball court
Yeah You saw there's a building right
across adjacent to that
so there we have a medical clinic for
anybody with no insurance.
Nice. That's actually pretty cool.
>> That's That's cool. Yeah. So, that's
been running for about 16 17 years now.
Um so, a lot of
families come there with no insurance,
chronic diseases, immediate
high weights, things like that. Yeah,
that's awesome. I've never sat in a
lecture before. I've been to prayer
times a few times. Never sat in a
lecture. More More so in smaller
mosques.
Is he like a prominent figure in the
Yes, he is our educational director.
So, Who am I This is a lecture that is
going on and they just get a small
of
Everybody needs some spiritual
Yeah, listening. Yes.
You're tired with work and all kinds of
stuff.
But, they teamed up with a church to
give out blankets during the cold.
Thousands of them. Yeah.
And they got like 3 2 kg
take blankets.
So, we gave them the thousand beanies,
thousand gloves,
non-perishable snacks. Yeah.
So, if you come together, you
>> [clears throat]
>> That's what we stand for.
>> Yeah, you can do a lot.
That's what we stand for.
Well, Sameer, man, this was an absolute
pleasure. Uh
we've we've been to probably about uh
probably about five different mosques,
probably five or six different mosques,
like just in our lifetime. And uh this
was one of the warmest
uh experiences that we felt. So, so I
will thank you, man. Thank you so much.
This is This is dope. This is such a
great great time.
arrange you everything whatever we need.
You know, in this world he creates so
many things.
>> [snorts]
>> I'm just
>> [laughter]
>> He He He's So, he told you to avoid us?
>> He don't want you talking to us?
I don't know. I just This
This is my first time I meet him. I
don't know why he why he say that. Uh
Okay, no problem.
Finally, you know, we all believe
there's one Allah, one God. You got to
believe in God, right? Sure. The same
God, the same Allah. He mentioned that
he is the one who created us. He is the
one who provided us. He say
I'm creating mankind is only for, you
know, to obey him. That's only the
purpose.
The mankind he create only for, you
know, to obey in God, to obey in Allah.
Mhm.
You obey him in this life.
If the man the one who obey him, he say
he give you peace in this life and here
after.
If you obey him, you got this is this is
our responsibility. If we turn away from
him,
we will be, you know,
we will be lost even in this life and
here after.
That's why he revealed the many
religion. He sent many prophet, you
know, prophet Moses came, Jesus came,
Solomon, David, Abraham. There's a lot
of prophet came to teach the people.
Yeah. You know, one after another.
You know, the final prophet was the
prophet Muhammad and last religion is
Islam. That is why you see only Islam
are still practice everything. The way
how we pray, how we fast, even the way
how we dress. Look at our women, they
still, you know. You get that in in
Orthodox Christianity, they dress, they,
you know, put on the robes and thobes
and Because
your religion also from God,
not for this time. Really?
Because after after Christianity,
God revealed the Islam. So Let me give
you example.
Let me give you example. Let me finish
it.
>> really quick cuz cuz Jesus says that for
God so loved the world that he gave his
only son that whoever believes in him
should not perish but have everlasting
life. And so Jesus says that he is
actually for the entire world. He tells
his disciples, he says, "Go out to all
nations and baptize in the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit,
teaching them all that I've commanded
you to do." So Jesus says that his his
message um is for everyone for all time.
Yeah, yeah. This is I believe this is
right.
>> Mhm. But not for this time.
But if Jesus says it's for this time He
said this is for the time when he's
alive, when he was in this this world.
But after him, God sent another prophet,
another religion. Let me give very
simple example. Let's say let's say you
know
you work a warehouse company.
>> Yeah.
>> You know? Mhm. You work a company. Mhm.
There is a manager. There is a leader.
You have to obey. You have to listen
whatever they say. Yeah. But when the
one manager, when he quit the job, when
he leave the job, another manager came.
You cannot say I follow my previous
manager. You cannot say it.
Because [clears throat] his time is
already done. Same thing, you know.
There's many prophet came one after
another.
But their time is finished. You have to
follow the last one, the final one.
Don't you believe that Jesus is coming
back to at the at the end? Yes, I
believe. So then wouldn't that make
Yeah.
Okay.
No, yeah, that's that's fair.
Fair. Fair enough.
Fair. Fair. Fair. Please Please, come to
the Islam. If you want to success, if
you want to peace, real peace in this
life and here after.
>> I have it in the gospel, brother. That's
That's what Jesus says, if you want
peace, come to me.
>> [laughter]
>> That's what he said. go too deep because
I don't have no time. For sure. I have
to meet many of them.
>> Of course. We'll We'll be back.
Hopefully we can meet you again,
brother. I show you one verse.
In the Quran? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Awesome.
Because this is for everyone. Okay. One
day Allah will guide you, inshallah.
Can I show you my favorite verse in the
Quran, too?
Awesome. I'll read this. Yes. All right,
this is chapter 16, verse 97. It says,
"Whoever does righteousness, whether
male or female,
while he [clears throat] is a believer,
we will surely cause him to live a good
life, and we will surely give them their
reward according to the best of what
they used to do."
Awesome.
>> Did it What Allah mentioned? If you obey
him, if you practice, he give you peace
in this life and here after. Another
verse I will show you, very short. Can I
show you a short one, too? No, not this
one. Just just read this one. I'll read
this one, and I'll read the next one,
okay? Okay. So, it says
>> [laughter]
>> Please read this. Please read this. I'll
I'll read it.
>> [laughter]
>> I got you, brother. So, this is chapter
20, verse 124.
It says, "And whoever turns away from my
remembrance, indeed he will have a
depressed life." Okay, that's good.
>> say, "If you turn away from him, if I
turn away from him, I will be going to
the problem. Depressed life. That's why
it's very important. Come to the Islam.
It's the last religion. Can I show you
one thing that Jesus said? Just one
thing. You can show me, but okay.
>> Okay. Okay. Just just just just to give
you a food for thought.
Huh?
I'm not very good at reading in English.
You can
>> Okay. Yeah, I'll I'll read it for you,
okay, brother? Um
>> [laughter]
>> Just one verse. It'll be one verse.
This is the video. Okay, so we'll read
is this right here. So, he says this is
Jesus speaking when you see red. He
says, "Come to me, all who are weary and
heavy laden, and I will give you rest."
He says, "Take my yoke upon you and
learn from me, for I am gentle and
humble in heart, and you will find a
rest for your souls. For my yoke is easy
and my burden is light." So, Jesus says
if we want rest for our souls, if we
want peace,
come to him.
That's where we find true peace. He says
that it's my peace or I'll just show you
one last one and then and then I know
you got to go, so just one last one.
Mhm. He says,
"It's my peace that I give to you." Hold
on, let me show you that.
That's John John chapter 14 in the
gospel and the angel. Uh
Let's see if I can get that verse.
>> [clears throat]
>> Let's see here.
Oh, this is really good. Verse 18, he
says, "I will not leave you as orphans.
I will come to you.
After a little while, the world will see
me no longer, but you will see me
because I live, you will live also." All
right? Because Christ has life, he gives
us life.
And then um
and this is the one about peace I wanted
to show you. So, you you say he gave his
life. Yes. But you know, this
>> What's that verse about uh my peace I
give to you? Yeah. I heard this from
many people.
You know, my brother, let me tell you.
I have this, you know.
You heard you you said you heard you've
heard this before?
>> Like I heard this like the Jesus died
for For our sins, yeah.
>> This is I heard from many people, right?
Mhm. Yeah. Oh, this is this is the verse
I was I was saying.
>> Is it that? It's really quick and and
then you can ask your question, okay?
So, this is what Jesus says, he says
he says peace I leave with you he says
my peace I give to you not as the world
gives do I give to you do not let your
hearts be troubled nor let it be fearful
so Jesus says that he's the source of
peace and it's his peace that he gives
to us without him we don't have true
peace you know that's the message of
Jesus in the gospel what was your
question brother?
Question I have the confusion you know?
Like many people say that Jesus died for
our sins. Yeah. He said pay for our
sins. Mhm.
But my question is you know my
When you think about it? Yeah you know
what I'm thinking about it you know.
Like let's say you know I'm the one
command the sins and someone died for my
sins this is not this is not possible
let's say you know if I do something
wrong if I break somebody car Mhm. and
the police take me to the jail Yeah. and
my father came
my father said this is my son
>> [screaming]
>> I love him so much
I don't want he he stay in the jail I
want he get free I will stay for him I
will stay I will die for him. Yeah. They
not they not accept it because I'm the
one
>> [cheering]
>> got trouble right? Yeah. Same thing.
We are the people now what's happened do
you know? What I see
many people they saying this Jesus died
for our sins Jesus died for our sins and
then they do whatever they want they
command the sins they mix with the women
they doing they doing they they they
what is called Those are hypocrites.
Yeah many even when they celebrate
when they celebrate they do all the
evils. Yeah that's that's that's with
anybody. I'm not saying I'm not saying
they are bad
>> and they still sin right? I'm not saying
I'm saying that misunderstanding.
But what [clears throat] I learn about
the Jesus after
you know when he return when he when he
going back to God when he going back to
the Lord?
>> Yeah.
After that,
the Christianity become very weak. No,
brother, it boomed. It exploded.
>> Let me finish.
>> Okay, go ahead. Go ahead.
>> I'm talk about the time when the enemy
try to kill him. Yeah.
Try to kill him?
>> Yeah. Like what I learn is he is not die
yet. Like he is not die yet. I'm not
going
You know, I'm not going that point.
Let's say he going he return back to
God, right?
>> [screaming]
>> Going back to the God.
After that, Jesus is no more on this
earth. He is not here, right? He going
back to the earth. Okay. After that,
what's happened?
Christianity [clears throat] become weak
because of there is no more Jesus. The
Jewish, the enemy, the enemy This is
what I heard, what I learned.
>> Okay.
I'll try to clear this up. The enemy,
they are so much powerful because there
is no Jesus. They say that we killed the
Jesus.
>> Right.
I got you. And after that,
after that,
there is so many things people add
in their in their religion, and there is
so many things they remove what they
don't like.
>> Yeah, so let me let me clear this up for
you, okay? Cuz that's a It's a good
question, okay? So, really so what
happens after Jesus dies and he raises
again from the dead and then he ascends
to the to the Father. He goes back to
heaven.
What happens is that the disciples then
begin to spread the gospel, right? And
they're they're outnumbered against
their enemies, right? They're trying to
they they thought they got they got rid
of Jesus. They try to persecute the
disciples of Jesus, but it doesn't work.
They continue to preach even though
they're being thrown in jail, being
beaten, they continue to preach, and
then thousands begin to come and believe
in Christ as the Messiah. And it
continues to grow all the way to the
point where Christianity, by the time in
in 300 in the 300s AD, becomes the the
religion within Rome, right? And it's
not by fighting them, it's about it's
through their life and through the
spreading the gospel message. So, this
idea that when Jesus left, Christianity
got weak. No, brother. When Jesus left,
Christianity exploded because of the the
the preaching message of the gospel and
the power that he empowered his
disciples with. Okay? So, then and
here's also another point to add to
this, too.
Interestingly, even with the Quran the
Quran says that Allah in chapter 61
verse 14, he said it says that Allah
helped the disciples, supported the
disciples, and gave them power over
their enemies, and that and they will be
dominant over their over the
disbelievers until the day of
resurrection. That's chapter 61 verse 14
and chapter 3 verse 55.
>> mean that we are more
>> Yeah. Yeah. more similar than Jesus.
Well, that see, that's the thing. This
is what Jesus says. Watch this.
>> pork. I'm not eating any meat. Do you Do
you eat camel? Yeah. Yeah, Jesus didn't
eat camel. Are you baptized?
Jesus got baptized and told us to get
baptized. Do you follow the Sabbath?
>> to say
>> Jesus followed the Sabbath.
So, you know, you shouldn't say I can I
can do that.
>> going to be like you when he's coming
back? Yeah, I'm I'm like him in the best
ways I can.
>> talking like you, come to the Oh, he's
not going to look like any of us. His
his face is going to be shining. He's
going to be on a white horse.
>> us. You don't know how he dressed.
>> [laughter]
>> No, the picture You guys still have the
picture. Brother, there was no cameras
back then.
>> [laughter]
>> All right, I got to go. I got to go
right now and
I have to meet the people, but This was
a great conversation, yeah.
Yes. Yes. Yes.
And I
I the last one I want to give you,
please come to the Islam. If you want
the real peace And I say come to Jesus,
brother. He's the source.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Because if not if not. Mhm.
Your outside will be fine, but inside
going to be burned. Because this is what
Allah say. If you come Islam, if you
practice, if you obey him, he give you
peace. If not,
outside look nice, but inside I'm glad
you think I look nice.
>> No, no, no, no. I'm not saying right
now. Oh. This is for This is for you the
long time I'm saying. I got you. Okay,
this is what he mentioned. The one who
obey him as a Muslim, they will be
peace. I'm just showing the verse.
>> That's You're You're right. You're
You're giving me what the Quran says,
right? And that's why I would say I got
to give you the gospel.
>> Okay, okay, you can say it. Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Thank you.
So, with with Jesus, he says unless you
believe that I am he, you will die in
your sins. He says, "I'm the way, I'm
the truth, I'm the life." He says, "No
one comes to the Father except through
me. Not through Muhammad, not through
Allah, not through Buddha, any He says
he is the only way.
>> Right. That is the time when
>> Now, it's forever.
>> [laughter]
>> Can you give me a hug, brother?
May Allah May Allah give you guidance,
and may Allah use you for guide for all
the men. Thank you, brother. Thank you.
I I can I can accept that.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, man.
More than welcome. Yeah. Yeah. How's
everything? It's good, man. It's good.
Um
we actually we have a debate going on
with
Jake the Muslim Metaphysician. I don't
know if you You don't have a Okay. I
just know you and I know a few other
people. Okay.
Well, yeah, we're still that That's the
big reason why we're out here. Like
we have a
conference
and then we're I'm debating out there
tomorrow in in Dallas. And then
but then also this like documentary we
were doing. This is his idea, too. Great
idea. That's a pretty good idea. Yeah.
So, is this is this where you mostly
come? Like uh That's somewhere I closely
live. Okay, okay, yeah.
Are you
did you moved out here to Texas or you
originally from here or
Yeah, I moved from Florida. From
Florida, okay, nice. So, what what do
you what do you observing and thinking
like all the
the the the neighborhoods that are being
built, you know, the Muslim communities
is being built like like the Islamic
center is walking distance for a lot of
Muslims. How convenient is that?
>> Beneficial,
beneficial, that's all I can say. Yeah.
>> Thanks God, you know. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
for sure, for sure. The fact that he was
like, yeah, you know, after the prayer
time they just come in here and just
hoop, you know, just play. I'm like,
wait, what? You know what I would do IF
I HAD THAT you know, growing up
in my church or whatever. Like I'm like,
man. I was I was jealous, man. I'm like,
my goodness, this is awesome. So, when
you when you see like our type of
content, what what do you think? I
didn't see nothing, man.
>> [laughter]
>> I'm not the right person to talk about
it.
You know, you guys are smart. You guys
can lock me in.
>> [laughter]
>> I got you. I don't WANT TO SAY NOTHING.
>> I ALREADY SEE A MESS ONLINE ALREADY.
I'm staying away. I don't have that much
of knowledge. I have, but it's good for
me. I choose this faith, you know what I
mean? Although I born in it.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah, of course.
Yeah, cuz you know, you you get to a
point you grow you grow up and you
choose it.
For for our peoples not a lot of peoples
make sense to them. Make sense like you
are Christian, Christianity makes sense
to you, right?
>> Yeah. But don't make sense to me, right?
Makes sense Islam is makes sense to me.
So, that's what it is. Yeah. I mean for
25 years.
I mean, you know, YouTube shows
everything, right? Sometimes people talk
this and sometimes people talk this.
It's just understand level of
understanding. It's a blessing of God.
>> Yeah. You can say that, right? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Anyways, anyways, where you
guys heading heading to right now? So,
probably about to go to
to our hotel's. Um I can take you
somewhere if you want. Some Yeah, some
food. Some food, yeah. Shoot. Are you
guys hungry? Shoot, we were we just had
a Have you been to Sultani or heard of
Sultani in Irvine?
No? It's like a halal It's a It's a
burger spot. Oh, yes, and it was
>> There's some uh dessert up here.
Desserts? Okay.
>> You want to come? Uh I'm I'm full. I'm
I'm going to go out to eat.
>> some uh It's good dessert though. Yeah?
Yeah. Uh next next time for sure. Next
time definitely cuz I cuz like we're a
little crunched, but next time for sure
we want to explore, hang out.
>> avenue [snorts] is uh Dessert avenue?
So, that like that means that's
everywhere.
>> [laughter]
>> It's just It's a very good place. Also,
there's Haraz Coffee up here if you
guys, you know, maybe for the coffee. Uh
maybe not for him. He He's a coffee
>> [laughter]
>> He drink coffee 24/7.
That's some weak coffee at the hotel,
man. Hotel coffee is trash, man. It's
not even strong.
>> Yes, yes.
I'm tired cuz it's so so weak.
>> You need to drink the Pakistani style
tea. I know.
Yes, yes.
>> It's very strong.
>> Yes. It's very good. I mean, once you
get used to it, you you done. We're
going to be back. We're going to come
here. We're going to come visit We met
Sameer. Uh hopefully to see you What's
your You Saqib? Saqib. Saqib. Saqib. So,
pleasure to meet you, man.
>> What's your real name? Avery. Avery,
okay. And where you originally from? Los
Angeles. Yeah, yeah, yeah. My my wife,
she's from Dallas. So, we got family out
here, but I'm from Los Angeles,
California, so
But we're we're going to come back.
We're going to come visit. You got to
take us to dessert avenue.
>> Yeah, we're And and the tea. Definitely.
Okay. [laughter]
That's what I told you.
>> maybe something to eat, you know. Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. Yeah, it's so so nice to
meet you, man.
Uh good conversation, man. Good
conversation.
Uh we met we met a lot of good good
Muslims here that's like just really
cordial, very warm,
uh open for dialogue, so got to love it.
Pray for that brother there, man. He has
a good spirit.
Uh just just needs his eyes open and
needs to be needs needs some prayer.
So,
catch you on the next one.